let's go back to my 850 vacuum okay
okay now suppose um
i don't know for whatever reason maybe i
don't want to pay it all up front
okay so i want to pay it in um i want to
pay it in chunks
because it's too much for me to blow off
in a single purchase okay
they say fine you can pay it in chunks
you can pay monthly or something like
that but we'll charge you extra
okay because that's what they do if
you're paying slower
they want more money like in the long
run okay so for instance
they might say we have to add
five percent to the price if you want to
stretch that out over time that happens
all the time
okay so if i want to increase
that sum by that percentage
how do i do it okay now really quickly
five percent we can if we want to work
with that as a calculator we need it as
a decimal so what is it as a decimal
zero point zero five good not zero point
five because that'd be fifty percent
okay but i can't simply multiply
850 by 0.05 can i
right because i'm expecting that this is
going to cost more
after they increase it by 5 but if i
multiply 850 by 0.05
i don't get a bigger number what do i
get
i get a smaller number specifically i
get
850 times 0.05
that's 42.5 that's 42.50
okay now this number
is not this plus five percent is it
okay it's smaller but what is this
number what does it signify
this this corresponds to what they're
tacking on exactly right this is the
extra
i want to pay for the vacuum and this is
the extra charge
so i can approach this question two ways
i can say good now i know what the extra
charge is
i can say therefore the final price
would be the original plus the extra
so i can go 850 plus
42.5 come on we can do this in our heads
can't we
800 and 90
and 50 cents okay that's fine that's the
correct answer
yeah so but like if you buy something
and you pay
in like the chunks um don't you have to
pay that
five percent every time you oh it
depends it depends on the contract i
guess maybe maybe not
okay now that's the correct answer and
this way of doing it is fine
there's another way though it's a little
more direct if you can work out how to
do it okay
this step here right instead of working
out this
extra the bit they've tacked on
separately i can go straight to this
number i'll show you how
okay instead of multiplying 850
by 0.05 which is the extra i'm going to
multiply by
1.05 can you see what the difference
will be
okay in one step
this one corresponds to the 850 one lot
of 850 the original price
okay this .05 corresponds to the 4250
the extra they've tacked on
i'm just doing them both at once okay so
this year this is the original
price okay and this here
this is the extra okay
so if you go to your calculator and you
say 850
sorry times 1.05
instead of 0.05 okay you'll see your
calculator hands you straight back
with 892.5 so therefore
898.50 okay
so two approaches they're both doing the
same thing you both get the same answer
was that is that just a question i
didn't think it would be 45
so i personally i kind of like this way
of doing it because it's faster okay
but if you can't remember like why do i
multiply by a by
one point blah blah then going through
this way it's a bit longer
but the the logic is quite clear why
you're doing it okay yeah so where is it
which part are you talking about you're
talking about 42.5
1.05 yeah okay that 42.5 is
hidden in here okay so
if you like what i'm doing is let's see
let's see if we can do it like this
do you remember your factorizing when we
did algebra do you remember that
yeah so this slide here okay let me
rewrite it
i'm gonna close this one off
okay how do i get 42.5 i got it by doing
this
okay so i'm going to write that
is that okay so original price plus
extra okay now in algebra we're used to
factorizing this kind of stuff you look
for the common factor the number that
you can take out of both
which in this case is it's 850. the
whole thing is there
right so i can write 850 out the front
okay now i write my brackets what's
going to go inside
okay how many 850s do i have here
answer one right how many 850s do i have
here
answer that much of that 850
okay plus 0.05
but you can do that that's just
1.05 which is what we had before
and that gives you your 892.
directly okay so you can go straight to
this slide but if you're not sure where
it comes from
this is how i built it okay